Hello freak bitches. Amen.
Did you hear that Nate Diaz wants $20
million for the rematch with Connor?
Is he and he should get 20 to 30
million. Do you think that it's,
how many paper view buys? Do you
think that that fight would be worth?
1.5 now. Yeah. Maybe. Maybe more now.
Maybe more now. Cause let
me ask you this, Joe. What,
what let's say Nate fought, let's say
Nate fights the winner of Kevin Lee.
Tony Ferguson, and they're
the main event pay-per-view.
How many paper you biases Nate
Diaz do without Connor? Well,
not as many. Not even close.
Not even close, right? It's,
it's a big kind of thing. But
the big fight for Connor is Nate.
Like if Conor fought Kevin Lee, how
many pay-per-views would he get?
[inaudible] he might. You're right.
You look up all condoms writes,
he's never done less than a
million ever. You're right.
So he's the Floyd Mayweather
MMA. Now we freeze.
Oh God dammit. Fight. Goddammit.
Fipass son of a bitch.
Conspiracy theory. Snoop
cat, bitch. It's Snoop cast.
Okay. They fucked us. We're
sitting here frozen outlet persona.
We will, Oh my God. Oh,
we're back in low. Done. No,
it's dead. It's dead again.
We've got a streaming issue.
Some shit is going down or there's
such a demand for this. It's fucked up.
Like Mayweather, McGregor, they don't
know how to handle the overload.
They'll expect it. 50 people
and they got a hundred total.
How dare you. Yeah, this is
ridiculous. Um, yeah, but I think Nate,
rightfully so, she gets that fights
can be the biggest paper of all time.
I really do. I think the trilogies
can be because of, for MMA,
for MMA framing may because of the
commerce. Right? He's bigger than ever.
Biggest combat sports bad.
That's poor guy. The ref gave
him that cut. But with Nate,
I think that the fight that the,
that's the thing with this fight and
that's why I don't think you're gonna see
it happen very soon.
Cause both Nate and Connor realize how
much power they have and you can't just
go from with the old rules
anymore. They liked the,
the Connor is changed the dynamics of
the fight game for the better for the
fighters. It's a great
thing. It is a great thing.
I just wonder like how much knee
can actually get. Definitely.
Cause what they say. I think
report said between the two fights,
he made around 2.5 million
to fight him twice.
Now he made 2 million plus to
fight him both times. Both times.
So it's 4 million. So 4 million
total. That's what I'm reading.
I did not talk to Nate. I did
not talk to you. I read this.
So I thought I made two maybe.
Yeah, you might be right.
Maybe I miss quoted that. So maybe
it's two and two or two and a half.
Two and a half. Either way. So
let's say made four minutes, right?
There's no way in the world you
can say, Hey Nate, fight Connor.
And the biggest fight of all time trilogy,
Tom's gonna get 40 million during it.
Two and a half. Again,
there's no way that happens.
Both guys realize the man to have this
fight and he made $4 million in a year.
So how much money does he have leftover?
You probably got $1 million plus just
sitting in the bank doing nothing.
So what do you, you know what I'm saying?
So the dynamics have shifted
towards the fighters for first time.
Now if you the UFC, how do you
make this work with Connor?
Because he's not fighting guys anymore
for five 10 million. You can't,
when you have over a hundred
million dollars in the bank
and the biggest star of
all time, what do you think the most
Connor's made in a UFC fight is?
10 mil PRI you think so 10 12 milk max.
So now you think he can get like probably
like 30 at least right at leap ends on
how many paper have you buys
otherwise why are you doing it?
What if he gets like,
what if Nate and Connor gets 3 million
pay-per-views it's not out of the
question. It's not,
it's a stretch stretch.
But if Nate can talk the
right amount of shit,
you know, and people get excited
about, honestly right now for Connor,
what else is there that's even close?
The first fight in MMA. What else does?
The only argument is you can
say Connor's the only drawl.
He can fight Billy from Afghanistan
and still get 2 million paper.
You buys are breaking Millie.
You let Conor fight Pauline
mal and Naji and Dublin.
See if I'm Connor and I have met Gregor
promotions, I'm going, wait a second,
I'm gonna fight this monster. Nate
Diaz. He won't pay me 10 million.
You wear Reeboks or I'm
just going to go to Dublin.
Me and Polly sell this 70,000 state
amount. I'm just gonna take all of it.
You have to. He goes,
Whoa, Hey, Hey, do that.
He's still got some sort of a, they
must have some sites coming up. Boats.
They have some sort of
a deal for boxing too.
You know they have that Zuph a
boxing shirt that Dana was wearing.
I might be looking at my skeptical
hip eyes, like the shirt.
I'd rock it myself cause
I do funds. However,
a McGregor promotions I'd assume
is Connor's thing. Really.
You think he's in cahoots with the, with
the UFC? I would think he has to be.
I don't think he would make a
deal with McGregor promotions.
I think he made a deal with what he's
saying. You can buy that suit for Fox zoo,
for boxing t-shirt. 25 bucks. Why does
it say Dana white, Z for boxing tee?
Does Dana white come with it?
It's false. Every teacher of him,
this is fake news. Um, I'd rock
that Lockton pay by the way. Um,
I would imagine he has some sort of a
deal. Okay, so let's say you have a deal.
Think about this Joe.
So let's say Connor and Dana have a
deal with the McGregor promotions.
They're like, I your next fight
we're going to co-promote with you.
[inaudible] well, how's
that gonna work now?
So then you promote this
huge fight and Nate's like,
hold up if he's going
to make all this money,
like I know where we're
in cahoots with him.
That's the way you mean for the UFC? No,
I don't think it would
co-promote for the UFC. No,
but I think it would co-promote if you
had a Pauline Mala Naji boxing match and
doable and in fucking Dublin [inaudible]
me, Britain. Do you want to see that?
You've been, I want to see everything,
dude. I want to see snail's race.
That's still ridiculous. The, the fight
is then a Diaz fight. That's the fight.
That's the fight. But is it the
fight as far as the business?
Cause if Kannan learned
anything from Floyd,
you know that when you fight
Floyd Floyd's the businessman,
he's his own promoter. He's everything.
Comma has his own promotional.
Now he's the businessman now. So cotton's
going, listen, what are we doing here?
What do you guys want to do?
Maybe if the UFC contract,
the Connor has runs out, maybe they make
some new, crazy, ridiculous look at it.
That contract doesn't matter if it's
out or not. The game has changed.
Interesting. Yeah, you
don't, there's no way you,
you keep going with that
current contract. No way.
Just found this byte. McGregor,
sports and entertainment limited.
The notorious Conor McGregor and
notorious. Why did you pull that up?
I don't give a fuck this little company
that it's officially exists and they own
these things and it's all Connor stuff.
Yeah, it's registered in his name.
Not mean it could be
like a tee shirt company.
It could be, but it's all these
tech, I don't know. Whatever. Sure.
I'm sure he's got something. I
mean, must have some sort of a,
but also Dana white. I don't know about
the guys that don't meet with Dana.
White's not stupid enough to let Connor
do all this and not be involved in it.
He's only really sure. Make your
own thing, man. Do your thing buddy.
There's no way. Hmm. Interesting.
I know. Interesting. Either way.
Whatever he does. Interesting. I know.
I would like to see them box Paul.
And while Nate just keeps eating tacos
and going to Cabo doing tequila shots,
I really liked the fight's going to
go away. It's not going to go away.
I disagree. Know fights around the
year that you think that it's so,
I don't know, man.
I think if Nate wants to just chill
and just train and have a good time.
The fights there in a year? I don't
think so. I think if Connor stays active,
I guess with Nate, what's, how are you
going to stay in the limelight? Yeah,
he's fighting Nate Diaz again. Uh,
they fought over two years ago.
Kind of hikes, not there. Paulie
Malignaggi in a boxing match in Dublin,
Ireland.
Legit possibility to get a win
over a two time world champ.
World champion in the second poxy
fight ever two boxing fights ever.
Two world champions making bank.
Come on, son balling. How much,
say how much ball was stupid?
How much money do you think you
would get for that fight though?
Not nearly as many more money.
They he'd get fight in eight tiers
with a tougher challenge. Right?
So like what do you think the paper view
would be for a Paulie Malignaggi fight?
What would even be a million bars
for sure. See, that's the thing.
Comic con could play fucking in a
celebrity softball game right now.
A lot of people are going to buy
that bitch. You know what I'm saying?
So him fighting Paulie and there's
all this heat, people are like, God,
he did well against Floyd.
We could see him being poly.
I'd say at least a million. And if it's
your own promotion, what do you make?
30 30 40 mil, right? Hmm.
Interesting. Interesting.
Bring your balls.
CARNA bring your balls. He, but
now Paul enlist. Everyone knows.
I probably wouldn't help Paul.
He's talking shit to all the UFC.
Well he should shut the fuck up cause
if you wanted to have a UFC fight,
he can go over there and get
his brain kicked in. Yeah,
you don't want that in his mind.
Stop talking. You're a boxer.
You're very good boxer. Just shut
your mouth. Just just go after.
There's literally a million people in the
world that could grab you and strangle
the life out of you and there's not
a goddamn thing you can do about it.
Correct. Sorry dude. Like the UFC is
not what you want it and you just don't,
your gun don't talk shit. You will.
They will give you a wrestler and he
will punch your fucking face into pulp.
Well he's not a goddamn thing you can
do about it. No, not a God damn thing.
You think he went towards Tony
Ferguson? That's probably way
he's thick right now, but
what's his weight class like?
45 45 47 yeah. How about you?
You give him Ricardo Lopez.
How about you give yai Rodriguez?
How about that? I mean, yeah,
you don't want that. Yeah.
God, look at the [inaudible].
Give him a guy that's not the top of
the food. Don't give him Frankie Edgar.
Don't give him Josie Aldo.
You don't need to do that.
You know who he could beat
up though? Oh, cm punk.
You'd start seeing punk probably
fucked him up or cut the fuck up.
Imagine what max Holloway would do.
The poly Mala Noche in an MMA fight.
Just imagine,
just try to just try to wrap your
head around the kind of ass fucking,
I think max went at him on Twitter.
Like [inaudible] would
literally kill him. He,
if he wanted to want it to literally
kill him. I mean, so it comes Watson.
So what a lot of guys are out there
doing a boxing match against not so good,
not so good. Max has the best shot.
I think max has amazing footwork
and he's a good striker. Very,
very good striker.
Is that excellent time and good discipline
and his endurance is phenomenal.
Cody Garbrandt might
have something to say.
Even at 45 you'd come and fight
Pauly. Be interesting. Be interesting.
But Manoj is a legit world champion
pro boxer. He's a fucking smart dude.
He's a very smart guy. He's one
of the best analysts in the gay.
Like you probably doesn't
need to do all this. Yeah,
well that was one of the things that
people were super concerned about.
Him sparring with Connor.
Like he did two 12 round sparring
matches with Connor and Connor.
He did a eight round and a 12 round
eight round to him. And Connor was,
you know, landing some, obviously
some fucking hard shots. Just one.
What we know when we definitely
saw that one straight left,
that fucking clanged him right dead
center in the mug and you see the sparks
fly. But also to Paulie's defense.
This was telling Paul like, dude,
let's say I'm retired. So let's
say Cain Velasquez was a case shop.
I need you to help me tram it. I need
you to come help. Give me some rounds.
That's not a free ride right there. That
punch. Fuck no, that's not a free ride.
That is the only space we can rough
that. That is your face getting crushed.
But here's the thing,
if I got off the plane,
even from LA to San Jose and Cain wants
some rounds, it Ken goes, Hey bro,
I need you to go five fives. That
ain't happening. I'm here to help you.
Ain't no damn you. Five, five,
one realm set on the side.
And coach was a lot of
ego shit going on there.
I think Connor's team brought Paul
in to fuck him up. That's the reason.
And to go, if he does fuck him up,
we're blasted out there cause
the sell the flight more. Yeah.
And that was the other thing that
he said, um, about that is like,
Paul was like, you'd never go
12 rounds like that. He's like,
you never heard of why you didn't
go 12 rounds. Never even in MMA,
I've never heard of someone get
off the plane, go on five fires.
What basically gave him a practice
fight. That's it. And it was,
it was smaller cars parked
because confidence builder,
it also solidified him,
shit, I'm gonna fuck her can box a
little bit. And then Dana blasts it out.
You know, I think it was good. It was
very smart, obviously. I'll see it worked.
Obviously it worked. Yeah.
Six and a half million
pay-per-view buys super balls.
You've created an animal. You've paid
an animal for you. The UFC, the hammer,
the God to what else the fuck
they have. What else do they have?
Strew versus Covello. I want to see
the full video. I want to give Paul.
He has full do.
You can see the full video where you
probably could get it and watch it,
but don't blast it up until
everybody. Because if you do that,
then you don't have a fight in
Dublin town. Everybody. Oh man.
You know what I'm saying? What?
It was like you can't cause let's say
Connor starched him for 12 rounds.
Well then that fucks up the paper.
You buy it. Then we're like, wait, no.
Of course he's going to beat
him bullet. If he didn't.
What if Paulie's telling the truth would
if a Polly's getting the most of them.
See that's why we want this
debate. So you buy the paper view.
If you're calling me on
Tuesday, that ass kicking.
You know what I'm saying? Like,
you can't that tapes out though,
but you can't release it cause
it's gonna fuck up the fight.
Maybe see when the security guards
were getting in his face, it's like,
relax dude, I'm a fighter. Yeah,
you just come out. I'm a fighter.
That guy kicked him out. That's what
the fuck you do. That's hilarious. Yeah.
He's like, I'm trying to hype up a fight.
Then he almost got in a fight during the,
uh, when we're doing a, uh, pre show,
cause the fans were
just fucking relentless.
Irish fans were just harassing
them. And then the guy goes, Paulie,
I'll kick your ass worse than Conor
McGregor did. And then finally Paul,
he goes, fuck this, take this things
off. Goes at him. And so then, uh, Brian,
uh, gets between them. Brian, the
calm Taylor with the shaved head.
And so he's like, no, no, probably
don't do this. And the guy's like,
do something. I'll give you a worse
beaten. McGregor did in the, you know,
his Irish accent, poly
can't get, don't buy us,
spit on him. And then it was
chaos. Scary. Scary for sure.
Getting security earlier in that though.